enfin
françoise sagan a terminé cette semaine
son quatrième roman sa parution
prochaine va-t-elle mettre fin au
silence sont l entoure depuis près de
deux ans sa vie privée la dernière fois
qu'on l'a vu dans les magazines c'était
le jour de son mariage
l'avant dernière fois c'était sur une
civière après son accident
tout se passe comme si sous cette
voiture une certaine françoise sagan
avait abandonné la danse
l'asag hang seng trope et des barres de
saint germain des prés du tout-cinéma
des voitures de sport et l'économiste
américain
françoise sagan partage-t-elle elle même
cette impression c'est la question que
je lui ai posé on soit sagan depuis deux
ans parle beaucoup moins de vous on voit
beaucoup moins souvent votre photo dans
les magazines je pense que vous en êtes
contente d'ailleurs depuis deux ans il
vous est arrivé plusieurs choses vous
avez été malade à la suite de votre
accident de voiture il vous êtes mariés
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
ces deux ombres vous ont changé en
quelques sortes
eh bien
changer vraiment nombre sa demande à un
modifié ma vie la vie courante
de quelle manière la maladie par exemple
la ligue serait couché et le mariage
parce qu'on est on y ranger la maladie
vous avez appris quelque chose
non mais après composera s'est couché
six mois max et qu'on trouve est malade
je pensais faire
et puis le mariage m'a fait que
présidera de la maladie vous a appris
qu'on pouvait être seul vous le saviez
déjà
immédiatement j'ai vérifié manière assez
sérieuse c'est une confirmation mais
plutôt quelque chose lorsque l'on
pensait aujourd'hui à ce qui vous est
arrivé à ce qui nous est arrivé il ya
cinq ans vous aviez 19 ans vous avez vu
tout d'un coup soudainement beaucoup
d'argent la loi est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est une épreuve qui est très
difficile pour la jeune fille que vous
étiez alors c'est pas demain l'épreuve
espèce de le cataclysme c'est comme si
tu étais un tourbillon vous vous suivez
vous voyez pas dans cette affaire s'est
pas aligné toi vos chances que comme
perdre quelqu'un ou se passait pas comme
le bachot menée par faire des efforts
vous suivez de l'enfant maintenant vous
avez envie de devenir un écrivain comme
les autres un équivalent par le capreau
confié lise j'aimerais bien vous écrire
des livres puis pouvoir en vivre et est
venu il a dit je veux mais ce que vous
n'avez pas l'impression que vous avez un
peu contribué dans le passé
cette légende 50
penser qu'on n'avait pas un peu et des
iphone écrivains comme les autres on
vous voyait dans des endroits très
publique
non en fait c'est insensé et je vais 18
ans alors c'est parti là dessus à 18 ans
je veux les goujons à 18 ans c'est à
dire enfin beaucoup de filles ont à mon
âge c'est à dire aimé sortir aimé danser
mais la mère aimait les voitures et mais
les bandes de jeunes stars alors comme
c'est et moi on a le métier de
journaliste et de majorer échaudé les
allemands dit mais vous n'avez pas
l'impression qu'il y avait dans votre
existence à ce moment là déjà une
certaine insolence
vous avez beaucoup d'argent était très
jeune vous saisit ce que vous voulez on
avait l'impression peut que vous
gaspillez cet argent je l'expliqué
lespillez montant gaspiller mon argent
je gaspillais ma vie et à 18 ans de
ressources qu'il faut faire
ne pensez vous pas aussi que vos
personnages d'une certaine façon ont
contribué à cette légende sagan vos
personnages aussi ont beaucoup d'argent
ils n'ont pas le souci matériel en
général d'abord cédé pour lesquels enfin
dans le premier d'accord c'était la
compet liberté toute manière moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le l'histoire le thème
que je que je veux raconter et les gens
dont je parle je connais leur milieu su
comment il finira et c'est pas la même
puissance ou c'est ridicule parce que je
connais pas bien mieux paysans ou c'est
tout ce qui m'intéresse c'est l'histoire
les gens sont des illustrations de mon
histoire oui vous même à ce que vous
aimez l'argent est ce que vous pourriez
vivre sans argent très dur parce que
j'aime et des puissants mais je crois
pas que je crois je transcris devait
être avec beaucoup moins d'argent mais
il fallait pas plus y est libre pauvres
on ne voyait pas la pauvreté croatie et
épouse je me tuerai pas mettra ce
versement en dtv vos personnages les
jeunes filles en tout cas qu'ils sont
nombreux livres ont irrité un peu par
leurs comportements disons ce
comportement parce que c'est le vôtre
d'abord vous avez affirmé à plusieurs
reprises non seulement d'en voler dans
les interviews que vous ne croyez pas à
la durée à l'amour
c'est probablement juste que je crois
que nos amours et très rarement longue
et entière sans que beaucoup de gens
disent ensemble par fatigue par habitude
par absence de vitalité comme ça un site
où les choix que l'on soit d'amour qui
dure c'est une chose est plus
souhaitable qu'on puisse imaginer ça
existe vous pourrez très peu d'exemples
jeudi enfin je suis ça ça existe et ça
va exister
vous allez lui aussi en très long et
marienval les enfants oui si vous avez
une fille est ce que vous vous
accepteriez sony pas vous souhaiteriez
qu'elle ait de l'amour l'expérience
quand vos jeunes filles dans vos livres
j'ai vu une fille je lui souhaiterais de
rencontrer à 20 ans un homme thélème les
poussées de brice et vit avec
mais ici sa confiance qu'elle arrive une
fois tous les mille ans alors si ça se
passe bien pour elle comme ça je lui
souhaite de devis de seuil et de phases
différentes expériences les rangs
expliqueriez vous livre à votre fils
vous lui direz je crois ça se passe
comme ça que les gens s'aiment et
puisqu'on se laisse et puis c'est le
sait mais à nouveau et que la principale
chose que les gens craignent c'est la
solitude et c'est ce qui explique
beaucoup beaucoup d' aventure qui n'ont
pas d'autres d'autre signification
on trouve généralement que vous avez
l'air plus est ce que c'est votre avis
non je rentrais et on n'a pas du tout
vous avez déclaré un journaliste
américain pour qu'un journaliste
américain vous avez déclaré ça m'a
peut-être pas tout à fait la même chose
qu'il n'y avait rien d'intéressant écrit
sur le mariage parce que c'est toujours
votre opinion c'est pas c'était pas ça
la question
question était écrire et vous jamais sur
une femme qui est marié depuis 20 ans et
dix enfants nous a pas dessus des
enfants marié ou s'arrêtent et charmant
mais c'est pas d'amour romanesque ceci
dit vous pourriez que sur le mariage
peut dire sur quel couple ou et mario va
marier
vivent ensemble